hi and welcome to serverless migration
station a mini series dedicated to
helping developers modernize their apps
running on serverless compete platforms
like app engine this is wesi from Google
joined by my colleague Martin and Porter
the train to help you get to your
destination glad to be here with where
is Porter taking us today well in module
17 we show developers how they can
upgrade runtimes like from python 2 to 3
Java 8 to 17 and so on but continue to
use app engine's Legacy bundle Services
ah I do remember that episode so instead
of migrating away from those bundled
Services you showed us how the code
tweaks necessary for Python 3 apps to
access those bundled Services right
that's right I also mentioned that most
runtimes like Java go and PHP don't
require code changes only Python and
that for most bundle Services code
changes are minimal with some exceptions
which brings us here to module 22 to
look at bundle Services requiring more
code changes than the others that's good
I don't want to leave those users
hanging uh by the way uh what are those
bundle services that require more code
changes so here's the list of which
bundled surfaces are available in second
gen runtimes like Python 3 and the ones
we're looking at today are blob store
mail and deferred got it now why are
these services so special that they need
extra code changes
that's a good question and the answer
has to do with their legacy in one way
or another it involves a part of app
engine that changed between the first
and second Generations whether it's a
dependency on the web app or web app 2
Frameworks that are not available in
Python 3 or parts of app.yaml that are
no longer supported ah that makes sense
uh I can't wait to see the code changes
but I'm curious if more information is
available in the documentation you just
read my mind our documentation features
Pages specifically dedicated to these
three services and how to use them in
Python 3. they're also linked Below in
the video description for your
convenience but today we're diving in a
bit deeper than what's featured in the
docs and you told me earlier that the
code samples are different than the ones
featured in previous videos in the
series why is that Wes well that's right
so the code samples today are different
in that they're not based off of the
module 0 or 1 Baseline sample apps like
the others the main reason is that there
are no migrations other than porting
from python 2 to 3. so we're going to go
to the computer where I'll show you
shorter but still complete sample apps
put up the python 2 and 3 versions up
against each other and then highlight
the differences between them with that
let's start this conversation off with
blob store in module 15 we showed you
how to add blobster usage to the module
1 sample app to allow visitors to upload
a visit artifact like an image instead
of migrating to cloud storage like we
did in module 16 let's take a shorter
blob store sample and show how to Port
it to python 3. today's module 22 basic
blobster app lets end users upload a
photo pick something to upload with a
file picker once selected click on the
submit button to make it happen if all
goes well you'll see the image you
uploaded the app is fairly basic as it
doesn't provide for downloads other than
performing The One download to confirm
that your upload succeeded now let's
compare the python 2 web app 2 version
to the Python 3 flash version starting
with app.yaml the updates to app.yaml
are similar to those we've already seen
throughout this series change the run
time to a supported Python 3 version
today that would be 3.9 or 310 and
delete everything else to use bundled
services in Python 3 add an app engine
apis directive set to True finally
python 3's pick-link protocol is
backwards incompatible to python 2s so
add this environment variable telling
app Vision to use a lower level protocol
that both understand this is needed for
Python 3 apps that use app engine NDB to
talk to datastore you'll see this
environment variable in all of the
python3 app.yaml files today
migrating away from web app 2 is
required to move to Python 3 so we
arbitrarily chose flask web app 2 apps
run almost exclusively on app engine but
flask apps run on app engine and most
other hosting Services increasing the
portability of your app to use flask or
other whiskey Frameworks create a
requirements that txt file specifying
third-party packages namely flask and
the app engine SDK the latter of which
we enabled in app.yaml a moment ago
that's it for config moving to main.py
replace the web app to import at the top
with what we need from flask also import
the app engine SDK whiskey wrapper to
access bundled services in Python 3.
blobster functionality has been moved
out of the original web app framework
into the app engine SDK so swap the
import of its handlers from web app to
The Blob store component of the SDK next
instantiate the flask app and whiskey
wrap it
the photo upload data model stays
identical containing just the blob key
for the uploaded image file the photo
upload Handler's base class now comes
directly from blob store instead of web
app and finally so the user can view
what they uploaded switch the redirect
style from web app 2 to flask
flask routes to functions while web app
2 routes to hand their classes so to do
this with flask a new upload photo
function is added to handle the post
request it then instantiates the Handler
class and calls its post method now do
something similar with the view photo
Handler switch the base class from web
app to blob store and try to get the
blob key if successful send the blob to
the user an HTTP header for the content
type is set so that app engine can
provide its best guess rather than
taking flask's default and like the
upload Handler we need to create a
function for the flask route which
instantiates The View Handler and calls
its get method with the images block key
finally replace the web app 2 main
Handler class with a flask equivalent
flask functions are route decorated so
the web app 2 routing dispatch table
isn't needed so remove it and that's it
for blob store feel free to try either
the python 2 or 3 versions of this app
or both using the usual gcloud app
deploy command followed by visiting the
app in a browser window you'll find that
both apps work identically
moving on to deferred if you're new to
this service it's a higher level
abstraction for spawning extra work to
run later it uses the default push task
queue but doesn't require you to know
how to set up or use push queues all you
do as a developer is specify a function
to run later along with required
parameters
the sample app is just a basic Auto
increment encounter starting at zero if
you visit the app it'll go up by one hit
it again it's now a 2 and so on switch
the runtime in the app.yaml file from
python 2 to a current Python 3 version
like 310 and delete everything else the
Handler for deferred comes on by default
in Python 3 so you don't need to specify
this in the built-in section like with
python 2. add the app engine SDK
directive and pickling protocol
environment variable as far as the app
goes the updates will mostly be familiar
replace web app 2's import with flask
and add an import of the whiskey wrapper
instantiate flask like you use rule then
call the whiskey wrapper but one
difference here is to pass in the use
deferred parameter with a True Value to
enable the Deferred service the basic
counter and its increment functions stay
identical now replace the web app 2 main
Handler class with a flask main Handler
function the call to defer execution of
the counter bumper is identical on both
sides last but not least remove the web
2 routing table
as with blob store feel free to deploy
either deferred app and discover that
they both work identically the most
interesting one today is email taking a
step back the mail service gives app
engine apps the ability to send or
receive email sending email stays the
same meaning there are no code
differences upgrading from python 2 to
3. what is different is in receiving
email now you may be thinking yeah
sending email I get it but receiving
messages means your users are emailing
an app and what can you possibly do with
that boy have I got a video for you I
made this one a while back showing how
you can change the world in just 10
lines of code supporting inbound email
check it out for your next startup idea
the basic app featured today saves the
last email it's received when visiting
the app it will display that email
message along with expected metadata
like the sender time stamp and subject
line now let's take a look at the app
in app.yaml replace the runtime with a
current Python 3 version like 310 and
delete almost everything else keeping
the inbound Services section add the app
engine SDK to access the bundle services
and the pickling protocol environment
variable
in the main app import the Escape
function in Python 2 it's in the CGI
module but it got moved in Python 3 to
the HTML package now replace web app 2
with flask like with blob store import
the mail handlers from the mail
component of the app engine SDK instead
of web app lastly import the whiskey
wrapper there are constants for the
entity keystring and the email headers
we're interested in the email body is
also important even though it's not in
fields but we need to do some processing
to get it so it's not as simple as just
copying a string like the other ones
listed
the final constant is the HTML template
for displaying the last receive email
with below that instantiate the flask
app and whiskey rapid the python 2 email
handle class and its receive method are
replaced with a flask mail handler
function when an email is received the
app engine system posts the message to
your app at the slash underscore ah mail
endpoint including the receiving email
address and the post Handler calls the
receive method with that message in
Python 2 the mail handler class extracts
the message and gives it to you by the
time receive is called but in Python 3
you have to instantiate the message
Yourself by passing it the flask request
payload the last message datastore
entity is fetched or created and the
basic Fields filled in
getting the email body requires extra
processing the message components are
encoded so to keep it simple grab the
first plain text Chunk found decode it
add it to the entity then save to
datastore like the other apps the main
Handler class and get method are
replaced by a flask Handler function it
fetches the last save message entity
turns it into a hash or python
dictionary then passes the values to the
template HTML escaping the values
finally remove the web app to routing
table and that's it like the others
deploy either python 2 or 3 versions of
this app then email your app and now
you've got that next big thing that goes
viral for today our journey is done now
you know how to use the blobster
Deferred and mail bundled services in
both python 2 and 3. that was useful
demo of using those special bundle
services in both python 2 and 3. well
they needed a few more code changes than
the other bundle Services it seemed
fairly straightforward and I like that I
can upgrade my app from python 2 to 3
without having to migrate off the model
services and without having to rewrite
all my code that's right Martin it's
good to be able to minimize major
rewrites which makes it less likely
you'll break something on the other hand
one challenge is that your app can only
run on app engine right you did mention
last time that moving off the bundled
surfaces does make your app more
portable meaning developers can consider
moving to to Modern serverless platforms
like Cloud functions and Cloud run right
that's right Martin Cloud functions is a
good choice if you wanted to break up a
large app engine app into multiple
microservices and if containerization is
now part of your software development
workflow there's Cloud run which you can
use even if you know nothing about
Docker or containers
finally also consider VM based compute
platforms like compute engine VMS or gke
our managed kubernetes service if you
want even more control like being able
to SSH into servers so while it is more
effort to making your apps more portable
it does extend your app's capabilities
in the long run
yes and if our viewers do decide to
migrate off the bundle Services they can
take advantage of all the serverless
migration videos we've already done
that's right and we've got plenty of
migration models to help you move to
cloud storage Tas Pub sub datastore
memory store and identity platform we
also have content if considering moving
to one of our serverless 2.0 platforms
like Cloud functions or Cloud run where
we have content for those who already
know Docker as well as those who are new
to Containers this wraps up our part 2
content on using bundled services in
python 3. be sure to review module 17 if
you missed part 1 which includes special
guest Aaron who's crafting a parallel
series for Java app engine developers
wow we've certainly built out a whole
rail system of different migrations to
help app engine developers modernize
their apps haven't we us yes we have and
on behalf of Martin and I thanks for
staying with us on all of these
modernization Journeys where Porter
takes you to where you want to go we
hope to see you at the next migration
station or on another serverless
Expedition soon in the meantime happy
travels
[Music]